[music]
hello know full well
there was an explosion keep driving
my husband has his office laughter in front
[applause]
that
the fatality was your husband the enemy was a muslim would
you have remembered how your family
killed but one  woman who
put bread for us today
clearly
it was at night where did the perpetrators
tore the fingerprints of the
two accused did they find
more fingerprints
so another person involved
honors my son what you did it
is in politics
the phone that's a symbol for this on the
banners after all only in trouble
imagine they would have caught me in the
car no
he survived no the earth
didn't take part in the whole skirmish
the viruses hit the weakest
[music]